a new report out this morning discovered
some leafy greens recently sold at
supermarkets were contaminated with the
potentially deadly bacteria Consumer
Reports says it tested nearly 300
samples of fresh greens like lettuce
spinach and kale they say they found six
of those samples tainted with Listeria
CTM consumer investigative correspondent
and a Warner is here so Anna
where did Consumer Reports find these
greens so the six samples I were in
various locations in about three states
Connecticut New Jersey and New York in
June it's a sampling but they did find
Listeria in pre-washed and the bagged
greens that some people are told not to
wash all the retailers are stressing
that food say safety of course is their
top priority Public Health officials
have not reported any illnesses or
concerns following their own inspections
and Consumer Reports does note the
studies not large enough to draw any
conclusions about a specific brand or
retailer but this is intended to
highlight the safety the overall safety
of the supermarket industry now a trade
association that represents retailers
wholesalers and suppliers that sell
products to grocery stores told us that
the incidents outlined in Consumer
Reports remind us that the entire supply
chain has a responsibility for safe food
handling and they do agree that you can
make improvements in that but the
important thing to note is that Listeria
can be a very serious illness for people
who get it and especially for those who
are vulnerable if you have a compromised
immune system if you are older adults
infants and young children and
especially pregnant women so you know I
buy those packages of leafy greens that
say triple wash do not wash because I'm
lazy and I don't want to wash my eyes I
think it's safe I do you think it's safe
so you what should you do to avoid
getting sick you know so what's
interesting about that is that actually
the food Association agrees and says
that government regulators also will
tell you not to wash the triple wash
that you're actually exposing the greens
and yourself to more contamination from
things in your kitchen when you re wash
triple washed greens so even though they
did find it in a couple of samples here
you know it's hard
the wash listeria off you might wash
something and it might still not come
off so I don't know what to do now what
yours yeah well you know then that's I
think why Consumer Reports is talking
about the overall safety of the food
system for this needs to be improved
with whatever improvements they can make
because you as a consumer are not
necessarily going to know if the sample
that you bought at the grocery store is
contaminated by Listeria yeah the ice
cream for dinner time you know what I
love that plan I've been on that play on
occasion I know that plan thank you very
much Anna